Hola Santiago Sí justamente como se lo
he dicho previamente Pedro Castillo
disolvió el parlamento cerró el
parlamento Pero los congresistas
señalaron que esto es un golpe de estado
y que no compete asumir lo ordenado por
el jefe de estado porque hay derecho a
la insurgencia a la desobediencia por el
bien de la Democracia es así que
siguiendo este precepto democrático los
congresistas le dijeron No más a Pedro
castillo y se reunieron para citar a una
sesión extraordinaria donde el
presidente José Williams haciendo
atribuciones de su poder como presidente
del parlamento sintó a todos los
congresistas y se dio esta sesión por la
cual con ciento un votos a favor se dice
contra
diez abstenciones se tomó la resolución
de declarar la vacancia presidencial
esto lo hizo José William señala que el
presidente Castillo no ha tenido ningún
motivo legal para cerrar el parlamento y
invocando el artículo 113 de la
Constitución ha hecho esta sesión esta
jornada extraordinaria para defender la
democracia porque señala que el gobierno
de Pedro Castillo en estos momentos
según las palabras del presidente del
poder legislativo del Perú sería un
gobierno usurpador Pues bien con este
resultado que acaba de emitir el
parlamento peruano ha dado pie a la
sesión a la sucesión presidencial que
esto quiere decir que se ha dejado de
lado a Pedro Castillo Pedro Castillo ya
no es más presidente del Perú por
resignación del parlamento y Va a
continuar la cadena de sucesión con la
vicepresidenta Dina boluarte para esto
se acaba de señalar que va a haber un
breve receso y a partir de las tres de
esta tarde hora Lima Bogotá van a citar
a Dina boluarte al parlamento para que
la jefatura del país para que
dinavoluarte sea investida como
presidente de todos los peruanos es así
Karina boluarte quien hasta hace poco
era
vicepresidenta de este país y también
tuvo
el encargo de ser ministra en diversos
gabinetes de Pedro Castillo se va a
convertir en la primera presidenta mujer
de este país Francisco precisamente
respecto a esto te quiero que preguntar
no una vez que juramente como la primera
presidenta de Perú qué ocurrirá después
serán convocadas elecciones qué
escenarios se abren
bueno en primer lugar Dina boluarte va a
tener que conformar un nuevo gobierno un
nuevo gabinete de ministros que va a
tener que presentar un plan de trabajo
al congreso de Perú en los primeros 30
días de que ella juramente y va a tener
que hacer un gobierno ella anteriormente
en semanas atrás cuando se le preguntaba
que si hubiese de ocurrir la posibilidad
de que baquen a Pedro castillo y ella
tendría que asumir las funciones de
gobernante señalaba que ella está
encantada de continuar con la democracia
y mantener un rol de diálogo con la
diversas fuerzas políticas del país con
los empresarios con los sindicatos para
sacar intentar sacar adelante al Perú de
esta crisis política que ya lleva varios
meses por no decir años y también del
estancamiento económico Entonces se ya
que ella pueda llevar adelante las
riendas del poder en esta nación
Sudamericana Pero hay otras cosas que
tiene a boluarte tiene alrededor meses
atrás se la estuvo cuestionando porque
cuando ella era ministra del estado al
mismo tiempo desempeñó funciones como
presidenta de un club departamental y
hizo algunas gestiones y al mismo tiempo
hay acusaciones de supuestas
contrataciones de algunos familiares y
que también habría hecho mal uso de
influencias desde su posición tanto de
congresista como
vicepresidenta por estas situaciones
inaugularte ha venido siendo investigada
y tiene acusaciones pendientes tanto en
el parlamento como en la fiscalía
entonces hay algunos analistas que están
señalando que quizás Dina volver retenga
todas las intenciones de gobernar Pero
va a depender mucho de sus manejos en la
política y sobre todo
de los partidos que tienen
representantes acá en el parlamento
peruano de activar acusaciones contra
ella o dejarla que continúe en el
gobierno la situación se pone en estos
momentos
inestable en Perú no se sabe qué es lo
que va a pasar inclusive desde el
Palacio de Gobierno se está señalando
que se están retirando algunas
pertenencias del presidente hasta hoy
Pedro castillo y que quizás él tome la
decisión de salir por la puerta trasera
del Palacio de Gobierno hace poco El
Comando conjunto de las fuerzas armadas
y la policía que ha emitido un
comunicado señalando que el presidente
Pedro Castillo ha roto el orden
constitucional y la democracia y que en
ese sentido ningún oficial de las
fuerzas armadas ni la policía tiene la
obligación de obedecerlo porque el orden
democrático ha sido quebrado Así mismo
la defensoría del pueblo de este país ha
hecho un llamado a los congresistas y a
todas las fuerzas políticas exigiendo la
renuncia del presidente Pedro castillo y
que se continúe con la sucesión
presidencial es decir lo que estamos
señalando que Dina boluarte asuma el
gobierno Mientras tanto están
renunciando Han estado renunciando
diversos ministros y funcionarios del
presidente Pedro Castillo desde Palacio
de Gobierno se ha visto salir a algunos
efectivos portando alguna documentación
y se señala también que hay muchos
funcionarios que han dejado sus cargos
en protesta por este rompimiento del
orden constitucional antes del mediodía
Pedro Castillo dirigió un mensaje a los
peruanos anunciando el cierre del
Congreso la fiscalía el poder judicial
señaló que va a asumir un gobierno de
emergencia por nueve meses y que tras el
cual se convocaba elecciones pues bien
este situación de hechos ha desembocado
que el parlamento ejecute una reunión de
emergencia con los resultados que ya
hemos visto que se ha declarado la
vacancia presidencial de Pedro Castillo
Francisco estamos viendo imágenes de
gente ya congregada contanos que está
ocurriendo a nivel de repercusiones en
la sociedad vemos personas en las calles
en las afueras del congreso
Sí justamente debo señalar que son
varios manifestantes unos a favor y
otros en contra de Pedro Castillo
están protestando porque la mayoría
señala que esto es un golpe de estado
que habría sido ejecutado a través de
Pedro Castillo para evadir las
acusaciones de la fiscalía tiene seis
acusaciones por presunta corrupción y
precisamente hoy el parlamento iba a
ejecutar un
una sesión de vacancia presidencial por
los supuestos delitos de tráfico e
influencias organización criminal y
colusión el congreso ha asumido Las
investigaciones de la fiscalía y también
en la moción de vacancia presidencial lo
estaba
mejor dicho acusando porque él según Las
investigaciones habría hecho mal uso del
poder nombrando a funcionarios quienes
altamente cuestionados con la finalidad
de responder a intereses personales
también se ha estado señalando que Pedro
Castillo ha estado obstaculizando a la
justicia y precisamente uno de las
estrategias que había montado se acuerdo
a los legisladores es nombrar un nuevo
gabinete de ministros dirigido por la
actual primer ministra
en Betsy Chávez que se señalaba que ella
también era cuestionada por haber hecho
uso de tráfico de influencias para
contratar personas allegadas a ella en
el aparato Estatal entonces
su Estilo de de gobierno iba a ser de
confrontación Y por consiguiente Pedro
Castillo Estaba tratando de provocar al
parlamento para que este a su vez negara
una confianza a Betty Chávez y se
produjera una situación de crisis que le
permitiera Pedro Castillo cerrar el
congreso
como esto no se dio Pedro Castillo tomó
la otra alternativa que se venía
hablando desde ya hace mucho cerrar el
parlamento de manera ilegal